starting off this hours Nora
in California hi Nora welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show well thank you so much
Jay for taking my call how are you
better than I deserve what's up
no thank you well my husband and I have
just been blessed with a lottery winning
of 1.2 million dollars and it's a it's a
lottery ticket and we have the option of
having these 1.2 million dollars given
out over 25 years as an annuity or we
could also get the lump sum of six
hundred and ninety six thousand dollars
we are blessed enough to have our
wholeness paid off we have a lot of
investments as a matter of fact with one
of your smart vest errs here in
California and we have an monthly income
gross income of 17,000 863 the reason
we're trying to figure out which is
going to be the best move for us is my
husband was a state employee and his his
two pensions will be reduced in the
event that something happens to him our
pensions will be reduced by half and his
thought was well the $4,000 a month will
make up for that lost income or we take
the lump sum and invest for the 11 years
that we paid college tuition that we
couldn't use for investment and maybe
you work on some health projects it's
not an easy decision is it actually it
is it's really it's a really easy
decision you will make almost twice as
much if you take the lump sum and
invested okay we did we did talk to to
our
vizor and I asked her I said in order
for me to let's say get $4,000 a month
how much would I need to invest and she
was saying between eight and nine
hundred thousand to invest well that's
being pretty conservative if you made
10% on the money and you invested you
said six hundred ninety thousand one
lump sum right right that's before taxes
and we live in California so we're also
you're not gonna get home with six
ninety no it's going to probably at ten
percent to get at ten percent you need
four hundred and eighty to create four
thousand dollars a month
oh and by the way the money that you
take out from the if you take the
long-term annuity crap with them every
time you get that check at home it's
taxable exactly yeah exactly and and and
in twenty five years it's not going to
be worth as much right as in present day
so if you take the money and invest it
with a smart investor pro and good
mutual funds you will end up with
considerably more money so invest about
four hundred and eighty oh I mean if you
didn't now let's say that's not apples
to apples cuz you're four thousand
dollars coming home is not gonna come
home it's gonna be taxed you only gonna
get home with three thousand thank
factly and so you know if you invest 360
that'd be three thousand a month thirty
six thousand dollars a year mm-hmm at
temper if you're making ten percent on
your money now I'm not sure you make ten
percent some years you'll make fourteen
some years you'll make eight or six
mm-hmm you know what the stock market's
doing in good mutual funds you've got
investments now you know how that works
mm-hmm no but but I know that I will
come out more investing them the money
after taxes and then I will leaving it
with those guys in that annuity believe
me that annuity is not paying what
mutual funds will pay exactly oh thank
you so much thank you very very much
no so the trick is you know the only
reason I would tell you to do that is
because everything else in your life
indicates you leave it alone
if you were broke and had car payments
everywhere and you had absolutely no
money and you had mismanaged all your
money up to this point then you know
you're probably gonna miss manage a lump
sum but your your indication is you're
not gonna miss manage this lump sum that
you would invest it leave it alone live
off the income that it creates which is
what you should do by the way